foreign
to thought this football match would be
a safe outing for his family he says
they were already getting ready to go
home when police fired tear gas in the
chaos of the darkness and smoke they
were split up
I knew I needed to save my baby I threw
him from the stands asking people below
to catch him then I jumped down to get
him my wife had told me to keep him safe
then I went back to look for my wife and
two daughters I found my daughter's
bodies at midnight and my wife's body an
hour and a half later
he says their bodies were blue from
suffocating
this is one of the gates of kanjuruhan
Stadium
now the site of emotional impromptu
visuals
see you again another day they sing
until we meet again
three of our friends died we came here
together as a group but not all of us
made it home
shoes and purses are scattered
throughout the stadium an indication of
how people panicked and rushed to the
exits as gas filled the stadium
Spectators tried to flee but some told
Al Jazeera they were trapped survivors
said some of the gates were locked
I was so confused I couldn't see my
sister or friends everyone was scattered
my sister was on the stairs she had had
a seizure during the chaos
survivors
caught up in this attack this sign here
police
evil police you killed my brother people
are calling for accountability and it
seems those calls won't stop until they
are satisfied that the investigation
will be thorough
the gates to the field and stands were
reopened for investigators to collect
evidence Andy says he hopes the
investigation will lead to
accountability now with most of his
family gone his days are quieter and
lonelier
I really don't know what to do I want to
try my best to take care of my boy but I
can't do it like his mother
he says he worries about the day his son
will ask him what happened to their
family Jessica Washington altazira
Malang